now it's time for a review he's like
there's a guy he's like oh I don't like
praxis it was so pointless it was like
and then I start using really bad words
which I would tell you what words they
used but I'm a Mormon
and so nice that's our critic is out
he's gone it's Freudian but the video
game nerd has fireballs I need to make
fireballs to all I need is a lighter and
a can of beans you may think that joke
is beneath me but it's not so nerdy
nostalgia critic about lightsabers and
the nostalgia critic accidentally sets
himself in the Testament cause I sure
hope his Testament Kosar okay I mean
they re heaviness tears of chick I do
think they need to do everything become
savages super-mega robo geek and this
times critic
I'm your brother and the video game
nerds like no you're not you're right
but then he turns into the devil and
that really sure why I like boats too
except I need a lighter and spaghetti
mixed in guess with E it's a wonderful
dish super mega complete Jesus comes out
and he's like butchers butchers remember
Mormon and even though the nostalgia
critic to kingdom come
it was like the credit is due and he
pretty much it showed up video game
never works out with super mega kablooey
Jesus when all the sudden thunder starts
a critic is like Sean and they're like
the end and I like I don't know why
don't you tell me you're the one telling
the story I mean so they do another one
what are they gonna call it a second to
last final battle they know wait a man
we're serious this time this really is
the final battle at the end the
Nostalgia Critic is so bloody and
bruised in the next video he does he
doesn't have a scratch on it
what is he just a fast healer and on top
of that he wasn't funny
he's talking about this movie poster guy
there will be no nun bum action
well that sounds gross does that mean
what I think it's supposed to mean this
is jittery bouncing change change come
on William come on
I promise I'll do better than this -
acrylic can become fucking with our
money